بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين والصلاه والسلام على رسوله
الكريم وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين واشهد ان
لا اله الا الله واشهد ان محمدا عبده
ورسوله اللهم صل على محمد وعلى ال محمد
كما صليت على ابراهيم وعلى ال ابراهيم انك
حميد مجيد اللهم بارك على محمد وعلى ال
محمد كما باركت على ابراهيم وعلى ال
ابراهيم في العالمين انك حميد مجيد اما
بعد ف قراءتنا موصوله في زاد المعاد او
كثير من زاد
المعاد نقرا في اختصار زاد المعاد اذ زاد
المعاد الاصل كتاب يطول
جدا وقد وصلنا فيه
ووصلنا فيه الى
تدرج النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم
مع
المنافقين والذين لم يدخلوا في الاسلام
[Silence]
‏lost a page
here
yes we are continuing inad we reached
the beginning of the mention of
his
cs meaning his b عليه الصه والسلام
‏and some of the things that took place
between the muslims and the various non
muslims non muslims many tyes there
those who
hos there were those
who muslim but unable to a or unable to
move there were non muslims who
were
and not any kind of
‏ac isam in real they not muslim
they those
who بدر
[Silence]
الله سبحانه وتعالى في القران
زين
المنافقين ويميز بين المنافقين والذين في
قلوبهم مرض الله سبحانه وتعالى في
القران يذكر المنافقين ويذكر الذين في
قلوبهم مرض ويذكر للمنافقين انواع
ودرجات ويقول والمنافقون بعضهم من بعض
يعني بعضهم درجات من بعض في منهم غليظ
النفاق وفي منهم قليل النفاق حتى قد يكون
النفاق فقط في
العمل كما قال النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
ايه المنافق
ثلاث اربع من ك فيه كان منافقا خالصا هذا
المقصود النفاق
العملي فهذه
درجات are ty h who
inred enged in hyp to the
point a
skill a
‏those
who people
that weakness they dise in their hearts
they didn't complet believe in the prop
صل الله عليه وسلم in a way to
distinguish them entirely from
hypocrisy and so there are different
levels when we look at hoc at
wor we see the propet صل الله عليه وسلم
صحح
مسلم المنافقون في ات
ا in my na
me
wor hit عبد اللهي بن سلول
‏compl entire
tra any of weakness the musim have and
they any could
against however other num الله
سحانه mention that some them may be
forgiven while others would be in the
lower يقول
رحمه الله تعالى اول ما اوحى اليه ربه
تبارك وتعالى ان يقرا باسم ربه الذي خلقه
وذلك اول نبوته ثم انزل عليه يا ايها
المدثر قم فانذر فارسله بها يعني نبئ
باقرا ثم
ارسل بالمدثر هكذا يقول العلماء يعني كان
نبيا مع اقرا ثم ارتقى الى درجه
الرساله مع يا ايها المدثر لانه لانه امر
بالانذار وقد سبق شرح هذه
المساله يقول ثم امره ان ينذر عشيرته
الاقربين فانذر قومه ثم انذر من حولاه من
العرب ثم انذر العرب قاطبه
ثم انذر
العالمين فاقام بضع عشره سنه ينذر بغير
قتال ويؤمر
بالصبر ثم اذن له في الهجره ثم اذن له في
القتال ثم امره ان يقاتل من قاتله ثم امره
ان يقاتل المشركين حتى يكون الدين كله
لله ‏when we look at the entirety of the
propet صل الله عليه
وسلم his
biog the moment between when he was
first given the mage of
islam the first verses
الق the words spoke
prophet
said الفي الاعلى
23 years these
two and
23 الله سبحانه
وتالى ch with the change of his environ
and
circumstances and this is
important because for us docum
exact ‏that he went
through whether be levels of ag levels
of defense levels of whatever it is are
very important things for us to learn
and stud because any islam
goes the people who become muslim even
if it's one person their
circumstances can be
compared in ring to the
circumstances of the صل الله عليه
وسلم
الله for those in that position
are الله
وسلم
اسلام صل الله عليه وسلم ملم
اقرا بسم ربك الذي
خلق was the mus in the
world and he was not
comm call any elite
any that he was commed praise his
lord in the bic way
‏and of course he shared wife
sheded his
companions that that was the that he was
that inage
‏position
hearn and begin implement isam in as
best there are instan where the propet
الله عليه وسلم was commed call others
not just to call others in general but
to invite those who are clos to
him conf
‏toite his of
trib toite the entirety of his community
city of me then it was to invite the
entirety of the neighboring arab tribes
etc etc
expand this isan grow isam
wh however
‏ising blocks this now is
diverging from the
incremental الله سبحانه
وتالى صلى الله عليه
وسلم ex we
ex and this can be
d say for instance
‏celebrity
famous
mus would be great but it doesn't then
all of the sudden we inv this celebrity
all over to
give now
celebrity te isam ‏they have not studied
isam properly they have not organically
seen not learn the langage learn the
book قران per some
them of
قران let aling in arabic let alone
memorizing going through the stages of
scholarship and this doesn't mean that
only scholars give very
incorrect what does me for a
[Silence]
حتى قال ابن
حجر ابن حجر الحافظ العسقلاني رحمه الله
قال اصل كل
بدعه قول
قول الرجل في غير
فنه يتكلم في ما لا يتخصص فيه هذا اصل كل
بدعه ابن حجر رحمه الله
said
or
اسلام chr chris
‏even more ancient perdis
perhap
hind perhaps they root back to a prophet
some thousands of years
ag but now when we look at them and
weare them what happens they believe in
reincarnation they believe in the
trinity they believe that jesus is god
they
come هذه بد اض شي فشيئا فتراكمت حتى صار
الدين كله
فسد
accumulate until the innovation becomes
more than the
original and this progression is the
diseas of all
revelation revelation is revelation
because ites from other other than man
‏manel for reas الله سبحانه وتالى pres
fin
revelation do me that people won try to
chelation قران they do every add inov to
it all the time but pres in ‏will always
schar who are proficient
enough to articulate to us
exactly said exactly the messenger of صل
الله عليه وسلم said and more importantly
exactly what they meant with what they
said this will always remain in the
earth and that will be unch colc the
muslim has the entirety of islam
ى الله عليه
وسلم and so this prog this natural
organic
prog he receives
revelation he doesn't immediately become
a messenger he doesn't immediately run
down
‏slowly
grow not every in
circle
inle
equ
isic
grow الله سبحانه وتالى قران ‏in
incrementally a ver here a chapter here
a few verses here why so that it could
be useful to us
now when we know these the circumstances
this is what allah said now we have a
blueprint for any time or place that we
happen to be and so learning this
blueprint is something that thear
isam
presc ‏meticulously and with incredible
precision this has been one of the
primary focuses of islamic scholarship
from the
inception after he started to call to
all all of the
people then he and his companions were
now a minority of
muslims living among a hostile majority
of non-muslims
‏a h maor
nons these are people that areish
theming them antagonizing them
relentlessly
etc then he was all to migrate when he
made his migration now the state musl
state was established at that point
‏me to have ael of military action to
protect preserve interest every
country and so if we look in the world
today there are countries very few but
there are some
countries that do not have a
military don't have
‏infrastructure f
great يقول تعالى لولا دفع الله الناس
‏oric
natur وسلم حجره
مدين
that
ملين الله سبحانه وتعالى
‏viol compl
prit in their circumstances in me even
when they were a minority among majority
of
hle enemies they were not all to
exercise violence
with
that vi
اذنا او اذن الله له في
القتال قبل ذلك كان مامورا بالصبر فاعفوا
واصفحوا حتى ياتي الله
بامره
ثم اذن
له في القتال
ثم بعد ذلك امره ان يقاتل من قاتله ايش
الفرق يعني اذن له في
القتال من اذا علم انه في جيش مثلا جايين
او علم انه في حدا يقطع طريق المسلمين فله
ان يدفع يدفع
بالسيف ثم بعد ذلك ان يقاتل من قاتله يعني
بينه وبين قبيله او بينه وبين جهه معينه
من جهات العرب عداوه ما في
بينهم ليس ثم
بينهما عهد
فانه يقاتلهم ويتربص لهم
و
يغزوهم في جميع الاحوال انه ما في عهد
فاذا كانت مثلا في حموله او
كانت جماعه ماشيه كان
في مثلا ابل جايين من الشام في التجاره
فان المسلمين يستولوا عليها هذا هو
الحرب وهذا ليس من الغزو العشوائي هذا
للمحافظه على دوله المسلمين
وهم يقابلون بمثله هذا هو طبع الحرب طبيعه
الحرب هكذا واما المعارك الكبيره
فهذه تكون اندر من
الغزوات
الخفيفه ثم امره ان يقاتل المشركين حتى
يكون الدين كله لله والمقصود
هنا القتال الذي يستقر فيه
العدل
والامن صار دوله المسلمين هي الدوله
الحاكمه وهي تاتي بالامن لبقيه جزيره
العرب ف الان في هذه الفتره وهي فتره
العزه فتره
السؤدد فالان هم امراء
العرب للناس ان يدخلوا في
الاسلام ولا اكراه في الدين وللناس ان
يؤدوا الجزيه ويكون لهم مال المسلمين
وعليهم ما على
المسلمين او
لهم ان يقاتلوا كما هي طبيعه كل دوله وهذه
الدعايات التي ياتي بها المستشرقون يريدون
ان يتهموا المسلمين ب يعني يقولون انتشر
الاسلام بالسيف وما شابه ذلك هذا كلام كله
حكي غير مضبوط اكثر الاسلام واكثر
المسلمين دخلوا في الاسلام بالدعوه بدعوه
المسلمين
لكن
في هذه الفترات وفي دوله المسلمين وفي كل
دوله يكون لها نوع من العز ونوع من السؤدد
فانه لا بد ان
يكون سيف في يد وك كتاب في يد لازم لذلك
الله سبحانه وتعالى ذكر هذه الفتره وقال
لقد ارسلنا رسلنا
بالبينات وانزلنا معهم الكتاب والميزان
ليقوم الناس بالقسط وانزلنا
الحديد لابد حفاظا على راس المال حفاظا
على هذه دعوه وعلى
متبعيه ومتبع هذا الدين
‏and
so we see the natural progression first
he was allowed to use
violence meaning in a state of total
necessity after this he was allowed to
plan skirmishes he was allowed to use
offensive warfare as a deterrent and as
a form of defensive warfare
‏after tries
andin maor
ofs
then ofs
inin to esta jti in the land to esta
order to esta
law any ma
goverment people different
‏tyes relig so no was is no
was
يعني
is رحمه الله
‏undesirable for a superior to invite
his what mean a
person
person other
people
man toite is
‏no for those is and
so any des ent isam was always
option
however person to retain his religion
[Silence]
‏tr fr in
bad very
ironic for a country such america that
is absolut envel in
tax i mean we are
‏and then after that when you spend the
money taxes taken out and the other
person that earns the money taxes are
taken out when you inherit money taxes
are taken out when you win the lottery
taxes are taken out when you go to the
casino taxes are taken out when you
[Silence]
‏andic and then in this
environment what is is something which
is you know
unacceptable tax that every cz has to
pay
ta الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم لعن صاحب
المكوس المكس ما هو
المكوس
المكس هي الضريبه التي تكون للملك او
للامير خلاص يؤخذ قصرا من الناس له كذا
وكذا
هذا اسمه
مكوس وصاحب المكوس هو الذي يذهب للامير او
يذهب للملك وخذها من الناس هذا ملعون
ملعون من اخذها لماذا لانه ياخذ من الناس
مالهم ولا يعطيهم شيء بدل هذا
المال الزكاه
والجزيه ما لها دخل في المكوس لان الزكاه
والجزيه هذه تؤخذ فترد على من على الناس
قل فاخبرهم ان الله افترض عليهم صدقه تؤخذ
من اغنيائهم فترد على
فقرائهم وكذلك الجزيه الذمي يدفع الجزيه
لماذا لانه يريد حمايه
المسلمين حفظ المسلمين باس المسلمين اذا
كان في سبب لذلك ان حدا غزاهم فالمسلمون
يقفون و عون لذلك في
التاريخ افضل اماكن جلس فيها الذميون عند
المسلمين كانوا في
بلدانهم يقتلون
ويذبحون
ويسجنون
ويظلمون فكان النصراني وال اليهودي او
يسكن
في بلاد المسلمين كان يسكن يعطي الجزيه
اذا كان من من يستطيع اعطاء الجزيه وله
الحمايه وله كذا لكن
يقيم يقام فيهم العدل ويقام فيهم حكم
الاسلام لابد وكذلك طبع جميع الحكومات ما
في فرق الا ان هذه الحكومه حكومه مبناها
تقوى
الله والخوف من
الله ومبناها قول النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم من قتل ذميا
فلا يشم رائحه الجنه هكذا يقول صلى الله
عليه وسلم ماله ان يفعل ذلك
[Silence]
17 1 de of independence was written when
the party exed all these things the
american
revolution what was the purpose of it
the
reason was the
taxes they were being taxed by the kings
in
eng and their money was being taken even
they est
‏andan revolution was
bn that kind of tax tax which is
aage
is صل الله عليه وسلم
سبحانه again what kind of taxes are
weing tax that
are to a particular r leader the leader
is taking and not giv anything back he
taking
the this
عليه
وسلم right someone goes to col the or
someone is commissioned with
collecting person prit from taking any
gi even need sewing need
prit the the gift
‏is this is kind different than taxation
that we have in modern days so our taxes
for instance in america largely not
entirely but
largely taxes are based on a kind of
coal sy
‏taxes
basn andy is pulled together and
distributed in way of infrastructure or
pling or sewage roads right so a lot of
the benefits police ambulance fire right
rescue all these
things so benefits
‏taxes are returned upon the
cens that is very different than the
taxes of england in the 1700s over the
first colonizers here so the point is is
that when
islam was established in the land and
the rule of law law of the qur was
establ people could mus
‏and
where tyes of people no else nothing
el and taken strictly from five types of
wealth nothing else and no
else and all of that
isb among the community was taken from
this is
‏and is very
s which collected by the muslim state
from those who are non muslims they are
cens of that
state and what do they get in return not
just a tax that is
taken they get in return
protection
milit their land
صلى الله عليه
وسلم
a the me mean someone who
is citizen of the muslim stat is not
muslim this person will never smell the
of
parad is
incredible
war
that not mus me
‏in s and so their wealth their blood is
all protected by the muslim state they
get that in return and they get to use
the infrastructure of the muslim state
and they may be in some situations very
slim sit for even and so
‏this is the between tax and
and is some kind of evil thing is not
some kind of
wicked bloodthirsty you know as it as it
is portrayed by
antagon of islam and the uneducated
and
unaware rather this
is a protection and this is them
‏contu
toy isation for but very
ironic that a person who lives
in you know a place country like
america where we are literally
taxed taxed for being taxed our taxes
are taxed
right for us
to you know thum
‏and find be is
you what is how can make
non yeah how can you make an american
citizen born and raised they get tax for
everything you buy bubblegum and you get
tax for it right and the person who
collects the tax they're going to get
tax for it too and when they pay their
workers they're going to get taxed to so
the dollar is tax 20 times and it has no
end
‏forever and our economy is bas dollar
print
init meaning we only get our money from
the federal
reserve and dollar that comes them we ow
them interest we can get money from them
how do we ever pay
that
ir كل حال
‏r in
time the great
muslat اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا
محمد وعلى اله واصحبه اجمعين والحمد لله
رب العالمين next ان شاء الله
‏att